this podcast and every other podcast I
make is supported by patreon they got
this episode a little bit early plus an
extended card there's like an extra two
minutes at the start that they got
access to so if you want to support the
show s make more cool stuff including
more animated episodes which is mostly
the goal please consider helping out at
patreon.com I would invite philosophers
to be longer uh could have used less of
that James guy though
oh he sucks I I was like guys this is
they took me out of it please
I'll actually take spoilers I'll I'll
kill myself if I have to I'll fall on
that sort
um yeah we should probably give some
some to cry that that we're gonna be I
mean I'm assuming if we're gonna talk
about it we'll probably talk about it
all of it so yep spoilers thanks for
spoiling it for me I'm like well why are
you watching this I can put a spoiler
warning at the start but I eventually
don't click on something like this and
then be like I had Troy
probably wait that was you if somebody
says that I did my job because homie
looks busted one of my favorite things
Jesus Christ I showed up and they put me
through wardrobe and they were shooting
episode uh 108 which was episode seven
left behind and so I got to watch them
do the whole thing with Riley and Ellie
are sneaking through the town they're
hiding from the federal guys it was
awesome and this wasn't all on a Sound
Stage super cool
and so they bring me over to Craig and
they're like hey here's the Wardrobe
that we've chosen we think this works
really well especially in the character
of the game but it'll work great for all
of the different setups that we need but
it hasn't been it hasn't gone through
what's called breakdown which is where
they make it look dirty and old and not
like it just got bought from The Gap so
it was like it still has to go through
breakdown and Craig goes yeah break down
this because this doesn't last five
minutes in the apocalypse we gotta fix
all of this
um so that was my first introduction do
you think that you lost
oh my hands down no I'm I'm one of the
first first waves not even we're not
even making Graves for those people like
just it was too much of just mowing me
down yeah somebody remembers me and I
have a picture that's it that's that's
All That Remains they left it in Texas
it left it in Texas what do they do in
terms of like
how do they make you less attractive
Troy is it like what's the makeup
process you're going through there
because it is a trend like it is it's a
beautiful piece of makeup work they're
doing on you like you do look
fundamentally different very very
minimalistic but this is another thing
where it's like my makeup team was an
incredible loved my girls they were
awesome
um it was about you know 40 30 45
minutes at least in the chair every
morning to where it was this almost
doing rosacea because the main thing is
awesome they make you look Pinko was it
just that cold
yes yes and
um if you look Scott Shepard who played
David didn't have a hat on in that first
scene
um and his ears are beat red and that is
not makeup it was negative 16. Celsius
that's so cold it was ridiculously cold
and we had thermal like heated thermals
battery operated clothes to keep us warm
socks gloves long johns under and and
like heating jackets and they kept us
warm but you have to be careful because
if you go to two extreme temperatures
like that that's how you get sick
um so they were keeping us safe
but also it's like don't we don't want
you to be sweating through this like can
we take this jacket off it's really warm
yeah I imagine it helps right it helps
yeah we were stamping our feet and it
was like man it is it is so bitter cold
um beautiful location uh that we shot
not only outside uh Okotoks uh outside
of Calgary and then also in Waterton
which is just North of Montana just
across the border
um but yeah it's like making sure that
like these people have been exposed to
the elements so that let's and everybody
that you see in there that's all their
beards uh like that one dude that just
looks like oh this is Timothy is just
like or Marco sorry beer was down to
here just look these are vicious vicious
looking people
um and tremendous actors
um they were so much fun to work with
yeah I feel like everyone was fantastic
I don't think the shows had a weak Link
at all like just incredible performances
across the world
um no what did it feel like to um
spoilers get killed by Ellie oh my God
it you know if you play the game you
knew that was coming
um and I remember what's so funny is I
remember shooting it with Ashley and
just kind of like watching how this
thing it's like okay so it's gonna be
the picking up the Cleaver and then she
gets James and then there's the gunshot
and and all of that and to see how
they're you take that and the way that
you would shoot that on a pcap stage is
completely different than you would
shoot it obviously on a film set and
that was Ellie's cage is inside of a
Sound Stage
um and I wish you guys that there's so
much stuff that is that is clearly like
Bella fills the screen
um just just their presence alone is is
enough to just they could be a wide shot
on Ellie and you're still just like
pulled in captivated but the level of
detail that is in every single thing is
is astounding that well camera will
maybe never even see set deck was just
next level
um but it was all right unbelievable
this the set deck across the board of
the show I think it's across the best
I've ever seen like it's
they're getting it that that restaurant
is I mean to my memory is a spitting
image is that a set or is that a secret
different locations one is an actual
building in in Waterton which was Silver
Lake that we use for both interior and
exterior so when it opens and we're
you're seeing the sermon we walk outside
that's on that that actual location
but when we are inside and everybody's
eating and we're chasing Ellie through
um uh like going through the kitchen and
everything else that is absolutely on a
sound stage
um and there were I can't remember I'm
gonna I'm gonna do this wrong I think
there were 1100 different points of Fire
so I was gonna say Supply look practical
so that implies the set absolutely it
was it was activate and boom and it just
the entire thing just lit on fire wow um
it's incredible does that mean that you
can only do it once how does that work
no multiple times so everything is fire
treated of course so it was like shoot
it and then bring the fire back and so
none of this is actually burning so
you're seeing the fire carry through but
that's what would happen to real wood is
that it wouldn't immediately burn so all
we need to do is see it like that that
curtain goes up yeah which is a great
shot from David where he just realizes
it's all over everything is gone I was
talking to somebody earlier about this
today where where did all the people go
like in the town like when when you're
playing it's funny is watching the
episode with Neil had people over at the
house and and we're watching and
you know as Joel's staggering through
the snow trying to find his way into the
town I just look at me I was like
just the bells are the main thing that
draw you it's the fire and the bells
that are pulling you in the right
direction and to not have that I was
like man this town feels vacant and
there's this great moment when David
comes back and we you know we bring in
the deer which was a big thing it's so
funny how like we work so hard on this
one thing and it's like ah dear Zan boom
we're done
um and nobody responds they're supposed
like David's walking in expecting cheers
and there's just none and there was this
great look that we originally had that
we really didn't need which was you told
him didn't you like you you stole my
thunder like David was supposed to come
returning the prize and James when he
ran back to town to get the medicine and
another gun
told everybody don't worry we're coming
back with not only a deer but we also
found the girl that killed our friend so
there's this whole moment between the
two of them that we don't get to see and
we don't need to see it because it
doesn't matter what's most important is
that these people are David's set up the
very beginning I sensed doubt in there
not by them but by you no the entire
town is beginning to crumble
and just like we see that curtain go up
everybody's gone they're either in their
houses hiding or trying to stay warm or
they left and that's why the town is
just vacant when we needed it in the
game we needed him to run into people
because everybody he runs into is trying
to kill Joel to stop him from getting to
Ellie we don't need that here so we can
have this town that is now vacant pretty
much interesting I didn't yeah I I mean
I realized that my guess was they
weren't supporting him was that they
didn't want to
um defend David anymore that nobody was
coming to his Aid and they were like let
him deal with it because they were
pissed off at him that was what I
assumed but I think it makes perfect
sense that people are also just
leaving at that either fighting they
only went to the to the steakhouse for
church or to eat that was the dining
hall that was the communal space besides
that what do you see everybody goes back
to their homes because they're just
trying to stay warm
there's not a lot to do in silver Town
yeah I'm sorry
um
how long did you shoot at those
temperatures for I don't know I know
this is like questions most people
probably aren't interested in but I'm
like how long do you have to be in minus
16 to get something like this made as
little as possible we need to get the
shot but I mean we are how does that
affect your performance
it's everything it becomes real it's
like okay get out of here man uh what
are we doing
do we pick up this deer what are we
doing and that's exactly what you would
want
um so we would there were some days
where like all right guys that's all we
need was like no [__] like yeah we just
need to get this and light becomes a
very big
um precious commodity because if it's
cloudy and it's only a certain amount of
times a day it's like ah we're losing
there was in that opening shot actually
you see the light completely changed on
us it was gray and cloudy and then all
of a sudden the clouds departed and wind
picked up
and it was so windy and so there's one
shot when David looks at me and he goes
I sense down there and he's like not
from them he looks at me and I go and
the wind just goes yeah
there's not a chuckle in the script it
was just like [__] man that wind knocked
me over but it works
um so yeah as as least amount of time as
possible there were long days the day
that J that James meets his demise was a
very
long day it was about a 14-hour day uh
several hours in the chair getting the
prosthetic because there's this this
prosthetic that they gave me
um that had a like an attachment in it
that was a plastic clip with with
magnets
so that when that Cleaver goes in it
stays and doesn't look crazy so like you
could go Fink I could walk around and
then go and they take it off that's so
cool
um super cool it also has a a line like
a a tube going up that is yeah bloodline
that there's literally a guy with an air
air pump going
air so that blood shoots out that's
awesome the the I was talking to
somebody the other day who um editing a
TV show right now
and they had to choose several shots
where somebody destroys a wall and they
were like well obviously we went with
all of the best performance but it means
that we now have to retroactively CG the
dust from that wall falling to make sure
it's consistent and I was like you have
to do that on TV and he's like oh yeah
so they have to like surprise the best
shots and then make everything else work
together and I was like oh my God in
video games we just go more dust like
more
I have learned so much about the process
of filmmaking by just observing the
making of this show I bet because I for
the podcast I got to watch you know
non-final non you know picture locked
but also not no VFX not mixed
um and getting to see
what it looks like before like when it's
still in the oven
same John Wick three in the same way oh
my god dude
the visual effects side you you would
think is like okay like the infected
it's like no we just touched up the
Practical stuff uh it's like oh we need
we need birds to fly out of here and for
it to be really real Mike you don't
actually have like no it's already John
Woon no we just get the birds just fly
those out or
um the there was one of my favorite ones
was uh Joel is drinking something and
there's a note that comes on screen says
make liquid Brown because he's drinking
clear and I was like is that a choice
that they make so that they don't have
to drink anything else and Craig Mason
goes nope that is me being too clever
for my own good and I started thinking
about well if they're making alcohol
they're probably making like bathtub gin
so the bathtub gin would be clear and
then that's what I had him drink and
then everybody at HBO was like why is he
wincing when he drinks water because I'm
an idiot make it brown so it reads so
it's those visual effects shots that I
never think about
um but everything that you see there
that came out of me that's all practical
that is all so cool um yeah it's super
super cool so how did that scene get
rehearsed how do you rehearse like a
scene I just don't know anything about
this kind of thing like how do you
rehearse the scene when you get an ax to
the shoulder and make it look realistic
very very slowly very deliberately you
get all of the acting pieces out of the
way how are we feeling there was a day
of rehearsal beforehand you've got an
incredible guy was our stunt coordinator
and Maggie was the stand-in for Ellie
and the two of them like there was
always someone there going how do you
feel I mean and keep in mind this is
very shortly after rust so any time
there was any kind of uh weapon
regardless of yeah you would have shot
really soon after that right after like
like a week or two after this was
happening it was like what's the
conversation happening right now and
every weapons armorer stunt coordinator
was like this changes everything this
changes everything for us this is what
we've always done but but mark my words
there will be changes that happen just
unilaterally across filmmaking
um so it's just it's slower than you
think and that's that's what I I love
that piece of advice like it's slower
than you think so don't if you go to too
fast it's about intention than it is
speed because I can make it look really
really mean but I'm moving slower than
you think
um so it's walking through all those
beats and it's like what do we need to
see it's like well
she needs to have a moment to clock the
cleaver so that it's not just like
here's my beat where I'm I'm hitting the
cleaver so it's here's a way out grab it
you're the closest One Sweep over with
the right that needs to connect with you
don't Full Sail Out there's a moment of
like what the [__] just happened and
then the pain hasn't hit and so you're
still kind of clamoring a little bit but
your body's not responding right I go
back into the wall they're like careful
that's an actual metal shelf which I
absolutely hit perfect and then by the
way sorry apologies Troy if you got
muscle combat behind you then
up in this [__]
um and then it's just we need you to
slide down and I need you to not move
that was the hardest part because your
your blood's pumping literally and it's
like we need you to die I'm like cool
like your chest is moving and your you
know carotid could still be moving
that's cool but like we need you to not
breathe anymore I'm like
right and they're lingering on me so
much so that in the long take I'll give
a little Denzel single tear and I was
like there you go
sometimes they don't I'm surprised they
don't at this point do that as a VFX
pass on you like just to like freeze you
in place I would have thought that would
be you are I'm surprised you know what I
mean you always feel it I think I think
he always feels like uh that one of the
best deaths to me is that uh Nelson the
guy that played uh Josiah where Joel
comes in and gets him in the neck and
which is just such a great choice uh his
just look I'm just like
he looked so vicious in that scene uh
that's one of the best death faces I've
ever seen even even more so than a
Godfather when the the captain gets shot
the lick I feel like people are gonna be
so annoyed at me for saying this one
this this for sure we will have people
watch this episode if you've never seen
the show before but
I just watched Rocky 4 for the first
time last night Rocky IV yeah all right
I'm watching through all the Rocky
movies to get through all the Creed
movies because it times out so well with
my boxing match and um spoilers for
Rocky boa the way that um Apollo Creed
dies is one that I think like really
stands out to me in terms of the actual
physicality of someone falling on their
face and then just twitching a bunch I
was like oh damn that's messed up you
never see his face but it was like a
very specific
disturbing death considering the rest of
the context of every single other one of
those movies like it it really got me as
a good film to death it was a very very
visceral thing
yeah I really liked it I thought it was
really him looking up uh Rocky for that
hit me when I was in fourth grade I
think fifth grade
can't talk about the robot the robot I
couldn't I just thought it was so
ridiculous it is at the very beginning
of the movie is is absolutely ridiculous
the robots it becomes
but basically is friend uh it was just a
weird thing I didn't expect to be there
but it was made it came out in 85. you
don't remember the robot I remember the
robot but I remember the girlfriend
thing it like it teaches it to speak
like a woman
[Applause]
that's really enjoyed it I thought it
was a great movie thank you yeah uh much
better than the Last of Us episode eight
uh personally needs more robot
War robot yeah that was my Note too but
how was it working with uh Bella I feel
like I came from the beginning of
thought she's fantastic but I guess you
didn't really work with Pedro yeah
no I got to see Pedro do a walk and this
is funny with the the scene where uh
James is running around the house and
running through the backyard he clocks
Ellie on the horse and then I jump up on
the tree stump do a single hand uh Vault
over that rickety chain link fence with
my rifle turn and then shoot
um that was a second unit shot so
they're shooting principal photography
literally across the street
and that's where I see Pedro just
walking and just in his walk all I see
him is do is just literally walk from
one side of the yard to the other and I
was like
damn that's good like I just that's a
good walk yeah just the walk I was like
man there's just this physicality that
he's bringing to it and understanding
the scene that they're shooting him like
he looks like someone he's still
recovering from his abdomen being
pierced by you know a bat that must be
[__] surreal that's some Back to the
Future [__] like
acrossed away walking along like oh kill
the costumes
it's so funny this I was I was talking
to Pam about this last night the first
scene that we shot was when she you know
comes upon James and David and says you
know stop drop your rifles turn around
and
you know you
I heard her talk you know she's just got
this lovely you know slightly Northern
accent
um she's so great and then all of a
sudden she's standing on set and there's
this voice that comes over it's like
that's Ellie yeah it's a great accent
it's just oh my God like it's a
different person and
she's saying her lines but there's a
there's a a restraint to them and I'm
like
oof you're gonna
give a little more than that or is that
is that you know I'm from a larger group
also hungry and there's just you see it
just kind of like there's a bridalness
to it I'm like come on man are we
rehearsing are we shooting this what are
we doing and then it Dawns on me you
idiot
we're on us
we're not on her
and the second that camera turned around
it was like
out of the cage I was like oh my God the
control that Bella has over her choices
is
it's it's truly inspiring because I
watch like in that that last scene where
Joe and Ellie come back together the the
decision to not have any we talk about
this in the podcast too the decision to
not have Joel pull Ellie off of David
um was was both kind of like a practical
kind of like some logic questions that
come in it's like why would he we're
having this happen with a burning
building like what's going on
but the thing that I think we gained
from that is that is completely Ellie's
moment yeah I have no idea how long she
stayed in there with David
because we just see her come out and not
even like bursting out it's a it's a
pushy open the door and just stumbling
out into the okay I mean I think someone
counted it was 20 hits but it could have
been more it could have been a hundred
yeah have no idea it's a nice
counterbalance because without the
this me and Troy were chatting a bit
about it before we started recording but
it's another situation where the context
of the game has established at least
independence by that point so having
John come away isn't like undermining
that character's kind of or that because
she's already killed people in the game
exactly we've not seen we've not seen
that it would it would undermine that
kind of what that says about the
independence of the characters
uh in the game I'm replaying it right
now but I haven't played it since it
came out so there are some things I
remember and some things I don't I
definitely remember there being David
and Ellie fighting infected that is not
in the show that's the other thing we we
needed we could have a different version
of David in the game because we had
other mechanics at our disposal to be
able to build that relationship mainly
they're gonna fight together and if you
do that there's some trust that
inherently comes to that it's like okay
well maybe I was wrong about you maybe
you are this guy
we don't need the we don't have the the
limitation or the necessitation of that
in this we can lean into other things
about him
um which the thing that I love the
introduction of
the uh religious aspect
um and how how very subtly and under
underplayed that was
um because if you look throughout
history
when when people are deprived of the
tangible resources
food shelter warmth the only thing that
they have left are the intangible and
those who mean to rule
will weaponize those intangible things
like faith hope love all of those things
become the only currency by which you
can oppress and that's exactly what
David does so it makes perfect sense
there was this great moment where
um
when we're walking we're trying to find
her with David and James said well maybe
it's God's will
and it's this poke at him because James
is a pragmatist he doesn't believe in
this greater cause he's trying to get
through the winter and that's it and
like you said earlier Mike he wants to
be the equal and he wants to be the
right hand because he recognizes and
David this guy's the devil and as long
as I can remain on the right side of him
I'm not on the wrong side of him that's
where I don't want to be because
otherwise I'm going to end up in the pot
with everybody else
so him trying to make himself an equal
to David
by coming back with a deer and telling
everybody
all of those things are exactly what
sets him opposite of Ellie because Ellie
instantly shows up and David goes
there's my equal she's loyal
she's capable and she has a violent
heart and that's what James does not
have James will shoot the horse to bring
the girl down and say I got her but when
it comes to
put her down
he doesn't do it he can't do it he he is
choking and it's David thankfully saves
him from that moment because he realizes
he can't shoot a girl cold-blooded
has Ali that's one that's one question I
I had actually was like in the sh in the
context of the show has Ellie shown a
violent art at this point like again all
the way throughout do we reckon yeah I
guess very first episode when they sneak
outside the fence or outside the wall
and Jill freaks out on that Federer dude
and beats him to death what does Ellie
do she looks she wants to stop in the
face of the cut open the face of the
infected with the knife
she tells Joel do it get up and do it
she's actually killed no it's not isn't
it I know she shot someone that was the
whole thing is when she shot someone
before oh she said she'd done it before
she had killed somebody before that
person was Riley
so I did not put that together of course
that's why she said this isn't my first
time
did not occur to me that she'd killed
Riley she put Riley down huh
wow
that's rough
super rough damn
um I am I right in the read that I've
always had that David's a pedophile
or is that ambiguous that's text in this
episode right yeah it doesn't actually
say that but it's I feel like I thought
that in the game too but I don't know if
it ever is explicit about it there is I
mean as overt as you can possibly get
there's one little moment in the game
where you see the hands and then there's
someone has a lines as David's found
himself a new pet
um
there is a
the creepiest thing to me about David is
the justification of it I think if you
asked David you would say I'm not
I'm not a pedophile let me show you how
in history they would make wives of 13
year olds oh for sure
he'd have a very popular podcast
and you can talk it's the
[Laughter]
it is it is the justification of
circumstantial morality and I thought
his speech about the cordyceps was very
interesting
as well I don't remember I really just
don't remember that section that one is
that not in the game
I would I would need to go back and make
sure but I don't believe that the him
invoking cordyceps as a look what it
does it protects its own too he makes
that connection with Joel it was like
that's exactly what he was protecting
you that's what he was doing we do the
same thing and that to me is what makes
David truly terrifying is the fact that
he is able to justify to himself and now
to a lot of other people why we're doing
this
the fact that other people know what
they're eating
is proof of his capacity to control
because other people anybody in their
right Minds would be like are you
there's no way we're gonna do this like
somehow he was able to convince other
people to do this
terrifying yeah but also believable
that's like Cults 101 right
yeah I feel I feel bad for Neil
drachman's math teacher
okay whoever that was oh no you just
just did Neil have a bad uh a [__] oh as
far as like him
feels like Revenge
yeah I I love that line in uh Knight's
Tale uh Paul Bettany says I shall have
this he plays Jeffrey Chaucer and he
goes I shall eviscerate you in fiction I
will make you immortal I was like oh
it's so good
[Music]
um yeah yeah this this I think the
original question that you asked was
what was it like working with Bella yeah
and
um
I
Bella is just Fierce it's I I I can't
even begin to contain it and I I said
this at the end of the day like I don't
know how but somehow
Ellie's Soul just split into and found
two equal parts in Ashley and Bella very
different
there's different representations of
them but just looking at them and
watching them move talk everything it's
like oh my God you're you're the same
person like that without Ellie or
without Bella huh
hearing Ashley's performance and saying
you tell them that Ellie's the little
girl that broke your [__] finger I
mean it is sounds
it's not she's not aping a performance
yeah it's just they both understand who
Ellie is and let that come out and it's
just the same it's it's insane it's
insane
I feel like the two are super different
but it's also very difficult to I mean I
buy that they're both Ellie um but it
it's also difficult to remove
having played the game when it came out
from comparing it to the show all the
time it's so hard to to not do that and
that's one thing that I think the show
has done exceptionally well is
things that other shows would add as fan
service and this are not fan service
they're just the best option so it's
like if a line is exactly the same or a
scene is or a shot is exactly the same
it's not to make the people who play the
game go oh look how cool which we do but
it's there because it made perfect sense
to begin with so why change it and I
think that's an interesting challenge a
lot of people have when adapting things
they want to change more so they feel
like they have more creative license so
they feel like no I made that choice I
made all these choices I know what to do
but the the lines that are the same in
the shots that are the same don't feel
that way in this at all which I actually
don't know if I've ever seen done this
well before is that is that well I mean
is this the first time a TV show
adaptation has been co-run by sure the
original yeah that's in this way the
only one that I can think of and that
that's why people are like oh we should
adapt more things to it's like that's
not don't get jump on that bandwagon of
go oh let's let's do more video game
adaptations because we are riddled with
bad examples of that um yeah it is Craig
going okay I have some pesky little
questions as he calls and I love that
where it's like why what's fedra doing
outside of the quarantine zone why are
they the ones that find them in the
Capitol Building why not why not just
let it be infected oh well why did they
have why why spores well because we
needed a gas mask mechanic okay well
could we translate that into a network
of tendrils to where like when you're in
the
um uh the mall you could make noise and
stuff which is totally fine those things
are so in there by the time they've
grown into the wall they've been there
for potentially 20 years yeah
it sounds rooted in problem solving
rather than uh ego so yeah specifically
we're trying to solve issues
with the adaptation I suppose not
problems with the game but or just just
like it's not a province an opportunity
can we like one of my favorite
adaptations is or uh differences
divergences besides the bill and Frank
thing
is
what if we made Sam deaf now what we're
able to do is really bring a whole new
level of intimacy that would not have
worked in the game because you need to
be able to talk to them and they need to
be able to have parts of this
conversation so we don't have to have
that so what does it look like if Sam is
deaf now we now that starts you know uh
it's a tumble of of new opportunities to
express the same Stakes of the scene
Neil's perspective is or his philosophy
is to me is great what are we trying to
say and what's the best way to say it
doesn't matter what's the medium well
this is the best way to say it in this
is the best way to say this so there's
nothing that needs to be removed
replaced changed adapted anything it's
just it's it and it's a yes and it's
just it's not an either or it's like
well they should have done this because
they did this in the game it's like yeah
we did that in the game we're doing this
in the show does it what does it change
nothing there you go
both of them exist side by side it's not
like well I think it's a better you're
better Joel or this is a better Ellie
it's like there both and and yes and and
because all of it
it's what we were talking about before
you before we start recording as well
the kind of the I feel like the show
plays in very well into the strengths of
the medium throughout and and like I
said like where where I feel the game is
stronger that's because I think games
are probably stronger at those things
and you know leaning into the strengths
of TV on top of that just gives us a
different way to enjoy the story I think
it's great that transition from you know
when you see the bunny
the ill-fated money I love that they
kind of got that in there in the uh that
was great so good two
all you see Ellie and the stark white in
the game all by herself in the snow and
then
you push left on that stick and it's
like oh my God now I'm controlling Ellie
holy [__] the last time I controlled
anybody else besides Joel that didn't go
well so now there's this all new level
of tension
we can't do that in a show so what's the
best way to represent what that sense
memory moment was without leaving behind
a whole audience that never participated
in that that net never did have that
memory so that's what you're seeing a
lot it's like don't service fans
service the story if you do that you
service your audience that's all that
matters
but related to changes I think I know
the answer to this but it's a question I
wanted to ask anyway why the decision to
have Joel be stabbed instead of like
fall on the spike well because
in a when you're you know in a world
where you can get a make a med kit and
you're getting shot multiple times by
bullets because the necessity of the
game and you can just kind of heal
yourself and that is intense enough
you're like man I'm barely making it
through this
if Joel gets shot once that that's your
your life you're done it's violence just
scales differently in in a show yeah so
him falling off a second story you know
uh
you know second story building and
landing on rebar that goes through his
liver you know that would kill him on
our show yeah but we have an opportunity
here to do something that establishes
all we need to do is incapacitate Joel
so that we see just as we're beginning
to build this relationship it is
instantly
um threatened and what what does that
look like when that relationship is now
threatened by both of them and it
establishes a rule in terms of the
stakes that you could lean on for
tension throughout the rest of the story
going forward we've seen the consequence
where a show that's going to deal with
the consequences of violence to this
extent that puts more weight on it
whereas as you say in a game you have to
it's about legibility of contrast of
different kinds of Damages
penicillin right like the thing that all
humans really would just be dead without
uh we see how hard it is to actually get
also does penicillin work that way again
you just inject it into a wound I have
no idea that's what I love is I don't
where do I put it Joel
yeah yeah okay penicillin injection is a
whole other thing which also makes sense
because what is a med kit like that's
such a video game thing that what is it
in TV
penicillin exists in the game like she
she gets the penicillin
yeah yeah because she injects him like
in in the game
it's no no no and it's that I love this
beautiful side by side of just like
laying next to him and just God it's so
good
um yeah 100 works but the the
thing that we needed to do in the game
as well is
start showing you that we're going to
Joel may die and that where where does
this go and so that moment where your
Visions going in and out and now what
are you seeing you're seeing Ellie pick
up a gun and fight for you and say Joel
get up that that needed to happen for
the game but it doesn't necessarily need
to happen all of a sudden we're going to
go first person with with Joel that
would be weird in in the show so all of
those things are people that you know
Craig and Neil together going okay this
is how it exists now does it need to
exist like this now or can we do
something different if it's a better way
to say it then let's do that and being
unencumbered by what already exists for
sure that makes perfect sense yeah I
feel like those that writer's room must
have been
very excited do you know how long they
were they were making decisions like
that for
eign
get rid of that there was stuff that we
shot
um that
ultimately doesn't service the story and
there are there's this great little
one-act play that uh Nelson who played
Josiah he and I did when we're all in
that big town hall
in Todd's Steakhouse and you know we
come in and and David has the whole
among where he slaps the girl there's
the beautiful three beat of it too where
he walks over slaps the girl and then to
Joyce he puts his hand up it's like you
know
stay in your place
and then the hand to pick the girl up
that is the meals like oh that's the
most abusive just controlling
manipulative thing I'm the one who
punishes that I'm also the one that
protects it's just terrible
um James makes his way back over to a
table and sits down and
they all start to say the prayer and so
the cameras we have like four camera
setups and we're just doing every
possible angle that we could get and
Ollie come our director comes over and
goes you're not praying I'm like nope
and he goes everybody's praying I was
like right he goes you're not praying I
went yes he goes but everybody's praying
I was like exactly it was like why
aren't you praying I'm like that's my
point dude I'm not gonna be the guy that
prays he was like well everyone's
praying though it looks weird if you're
not praying I'm like yeah now if you
don't want to shoot that that's totally
fine I'm just telling you from a
character perspective I'm not going to
tell you where to put your camera I'm
just telling you that this guy hasn't
bought in and I'm not gonna fold my
hands and play along so what do you want
to do
so I'm sitting here in this guy James is
sitting here in this moral superiority
I'm observing everything that's
happening and these extras all these
background people are like and action
and they pick up their bowls and it's
just like people were like licking the
plates and everything with their fingers
they were every take was just full sale
I I cannot say enough about them they
were awesome for hours hours they're
eating going through Vats of this stew
which was actually stew
um that's something that people like
because eating is the worst I was
because I was a child actor and I
remember one scene as a kid if I ever
disclosed all this I don't think so I
didn't know that probably yeah
so so but I remember one scene where I
had to like eat a meal it was genuinely
the hardest thing I've ever done yeah
because you just like you say you do 10
takes and what was it it's just
it was actually weird you know what
weirdly it was stew how long did it take
for you to eat stew again
oh well that's the thing I was a
vegetarian
I kind of had no idea no you're
absolutely right ruins everything you
need eggs for years
kisses I remember hating as well yeah
you were stage kissing people as a child
actor like teenager yeah there's a whole
conversation something about kissing
right now wow
um but this this moment happens where
James just to wrap up because I gotta go
too
um James has this moment where he's
sitting and he's judging everybody and
all of a sudden Josiah sits down he puts
a plate in front of me
and one in front of him
and he picks up the spoon and this guy
doesn't break eye contact with me he
just picks with a spoon and starts
eating
and I'm looking at him with such disgust
and then I look over and David's just
daggers to me and it's pick up that
spoon and
eat so I do
and what we actually got was the moment
where I eat and it's like oh [__] this
is good oh no no I like this it's just
satisfying me and you watch as the
all the moral superiority and the
humanity just Ebbs from this guy that's
it that's the best choice for the scene
except for the fact that it completely
telegraphs what that there's something
wrong with this but the daggers would
have telegraphed it louder the dagger
look absolutely like you better eat it's
like well why why isn't he starving
because what we need as an audience is
to be in step with Ellie so when she
sees the ear it's like holy [__] we can
you're meant to be having your doubts
but you're not yeah exactly so I was
like man I've learned so much about it's
like it's not about your performance man
do what you do and then trust editing so
great I tell the story as you said tell
the story just tell the story
um there's a million things I could ask
but if you have to go I'm gonna ask um
well what was the hottest thing about uh
filming this episode
outside of the cult
um the hardest thing the biggest
challenge was my ego and my second day
on set was my hardest day my first day
was great
um I was nervous which I don't typically
get nervous but I there was a part of me
that allowed myself to play into the
whole thing of what if I'm not good
enough and the second day there was uh
there was a I had kind of one of my not
a bigger scene but just a James Focus
scene where he's kind of telling his men
what to do and when you see him in
control and all of a sudden we're moving
past that I was like uh are we getting
this shot they're like no no you didn't
get Pages yet we cut that I went
okay and they're cutting stuff now and
Neil and I were going to hook up the
night before on on phone and he wasn't
available and so I just started
spiraling I was like oh no I'm blowing
this word got back to him and it was not
great so what I do a lot of times I get
very quiet and so I just kind of removed
myself and just got kind of very tucked
into my own space and then the next day
and I love Craig forever Craig is like
near and dear in my heart because of
this he found me on set he's like hey
how you doing and he just has this big
big smile I'm like uh I'm better than I
was yesterday because why what happened
yesterday and I I just kind of told him
briefly I was like this happened and
then like Ollie and I just we we didn't
see eye to eye on this scene and he was
just like you're reading's so big like
all your choices are very very big I'm
like what are you talking about man all
I'm doing is literally looking behind me
he's like yeah it's just reading big so
like he and I didn't get off on the
great you know to a great start and
Craig was like dude you spiraled and I
went yeah he goes if that ever happens
to you again you text me and I will come
find you there's no reason for you to
feel that way we're not going to let you
look bad and it's just been this
recurring theme that I've heard from a
lot of great
whether it be developers or directors or
producers that I've worked with we're
like hey man we're very much dependent
upon you doing a good job but ultimately
it's not about you you see all these
people around here all these people are
working to make sure
that it looks really good and we're not
going to let this thing be bad and
literally everybody there has your back
yeah so it's it's okay to fail it's okay
to make a mistake and that freedom just
let me open up and and really stand
confidently in my own choices and and
realize I got the gig so do the job
that's all I had to do did you have to
audition
no not for this guy okay
because I didn't imagine so but but
that's that's the other thing was like
oh no what if what if they kind of like
did this kind of a silent scene
um every insecurity an actor would have
right like I can't get given something
yeah yeah it's like questions
thank you guys and all those people
helped you out obviously as you say and
yeah it was very funny to look at you
and be like wow Troy's a really good
actor even though obviously I already
knew that
five [__] times in my career five
[__] times in my career I've gone
[__] Troy is actually good you know he's
actually really good I disagree with a
lot of people he's actually kind of
talented
um I am I am beyond excited to talk
about the the season finale I cannot
wait for you guys to see this so much
anticipation like I'm so I'm so excited
to see it and I also wish it weren't
done yet and I'm enjoying the weekly
viewing and like talking to everybody
about it and I'm like yeah yeah it's
been a long time since I've been this
excited for a finale speaking from
experience if you got it in you
um there's
there's a lot of things that I've now
seen every episode at least two if not
three times and yeah it is it is
definitely worth repeating I I selfishly
I will I will say the podcast that I've
done with Neil and Craig has been very
insightful I've just learned something
from it and if if that interests you
especially if you're in the industry
it's a great if you're a writer or a
director man it is just it's it's like
going to film school with these guys
it's incredible yeah my intention is to
finish the show listen to the podcast
watch the show again because I do want a
great way and I love that you did that
it's so cool that that's oh man I'm glad
they let me this is often really
secretive about it like it's cool that
it's uh
um so the other question I wanted to ask
if I've asked you what your biggest
challenge was what was your favorite
thing about working on the episode
um
what comes to mind right now is that
every day there was someone who came to
me and said I just wanted to say how
much this story has meant to me and to
realize that everybody that was on that
thing like I I keep coming back to who
we call tall Neal
um who was our a camera operator and
he's just like this well otherwise
that's so cruel yeah
in the UK that would be a guy who's very
sure you're right it was a horrible meal
would be really short
answer
America's not quite that cruel she you
know camera Ops if you're on something
for three months Jesus that's a long
time yeah these guys most of the crew
was on there for a year and they gave up
a year of their life to be in Canada
freezing because they loved this story
so much so to me that was that was one
of my favorite things and just
I I seeing how everyone's responded to
it like knowing that there's now a whole
new group of people that are now a part
of this conversation yeah
um it has been has been the best part so
it's a hell of a legacy man hell yeah
what you and everyone else did on the
original game it's just agreed genuinely
amazing what that what that impact is
yeah we'll continue to be it's like one
day one day we'll do something about
that hell yeah baby level do you think
you'll do more screen acting
if the right thing comes along yeah I
just I I like doing what I do and I I
just want to find I don't ever be like
pigeonholed down into this is what you
do
um I
it's hard there there is there's some
stuff that I have learned some skills
that I've learned about how to move in
this stage specifically that uh it's
it's a challenge to do that I do think
that there's a lot of principles and
precepts that so far remain to film that
can be used in games
um and I want to shoot more games kind
of like we do film I think we've gotten
a little too lacks of how we shoot
performance capture and I think that
bringing camera in earlier having not
just storyboards but actually a full DP
that's there should be lack of camera
consideration is specifically what you
mean with the locksmith that is like
they're not considering camera enough
yeah it's this notion of it it's just
like theater like no it's not because
that's a camera that's a camera and the
second that I put a camera on it so if
you don't block it appropriately we can
move people around so if I was like yeah
but you feel that and there's just
something that happens when you go this
is the frame that I am setting and this
is the the story that I want to tell
um so yeah there's there's precepts
about and also working with actors who
are used to working on camera getting
them into a pcap stage is really really
hard and so I think there's a little bit
of language that I speak I can translate
that that to it and understands like
we've got that in the why but what does
it look like if we're in the close with
you uh because when you don't have that
tool going on cameras right here what
lens are you on we're on a 27k great I
know exactly what this looks like
because I've seen that and you're like
where's Camera 64 of them around you man
go wherever you want like I don't know
what to do with that
um and a lot of people lock up and they
get very very small so that's what I
want to see more from here is the
direction side like uh me too me too man
I think you're right that you can kind
of bring a couple worlds together though
hopefully we'll see what happens
I'm gonna go take my boy to karate hell
yeah
all right we can see if we can't Maine
is my boy Baraka
all righty thank you for joining us
everybody Austin could not make it today
I don't know he's busy doing Austin
stuff music things I guess who knows
what does he even do really
um I don't know I will I'm not gonna be
too mean because I'm off for the next
couple of episodes
too harshly off doing mic stuff I don't
know what does he do right you do
and that's uh Mike Bethel uh podcast
host
see you next week bye